while you were watching this what was
the moment for you I think one of the
key moments was watching them seeing God
Save the King
[Music]
we're so used to hearing them sing God
Save the Queen and when inside
Westminster Abbey they sang God Save the
King the camera went right to King
Charles III and I thought I saw him
crying today to me he looked ashen-faced
it was like the weight of all of this
Came Crashing Down you know it was 10
days of mourning that you're getting
through the paces every day all the
ceremony all the pomp all the meetings
welcoming all the world leaders today
with that beautiful service I saw in him
the weight of this moment he's talked
about feeling the weight of History I
saw it in his face in his eyes I think
another key moment was seeing Prince
George and Princess Charlotte I mean
Prince George nine years old second in
line to the throne appear his sister
princess Charlotte of course incredibly
precocious so well behaved for a nine
and seven-year-old at an hour-long
service we all wish our children could
be that way we always our children were
as well behaved as a Prince George and
and Princess Charlotte and then we
caught a moment at the very end when the
Queen's coffin went from the gun
Carriage into the hearse as she was
leaving London and we caught a moment
where princess Charlotte turned to her
brother Prince George and said it's time
to Bow we thought we could read her lips
and it was once again like she was
keeping her older brother in line and
that's the when you talk to Palace
insiders or Royal experts they talk
about that a lot of all of this Pomp and
ceremony is not just you know it's it's
about showing the continuity of the
monarchy and so I think that's why they
wanted the children there was to show
the continuity of the monarchy this has
lasted a thousand years and it's going
to continue to last
[Music]